we're back the event is back what does
it mean to see it back and seemingly
bigger than ever you know what it's so
exciting it's been so hard the last
three years not having a Gala for a
foundation that basically relies on
support it's been very difficult but
we're back we're back in starving also
and more eyes are on your world than
ever before it's been 24 hours since a
certain episode hit the screens what's
your takeaway from what we just saw well
it was so emotional as you know that was
filmed quite a bit after we finished
filming the season and so it's just so
raw and it was just hard for me to watch
because although as a producer you love
all the ins and outs and the shenanigans
when you're emotionally invested in a
group of people my heart really broke
actually for both of them of course what
he did it cannot be condoned in any
shape or form but still to see the other
kind of misery and the devastation of
the Fallout the relationship it was hard
to watch we're headed into what looks to
be an explosive reunion what should the
fans keep in mind as they watch these
episodes as we started the reunion
within the first two minutes I did think
oh gosh no way are we actually going to
get through this because it was a bit
like running my Animal Center it was
like sit and stay because they were just
so fired up and you know James starting
off and then sandable and and I just
thought this is Never Gonna Last but you
know we managed to get through it but
yeah it was intense but you know these
aren't fabricated arguments about you
know these are real people's lives where
you know they've been together for years
and years and years so it was it was
hard it was hard your executive producer
said there's going to be revelations in
this reunion that are even gonna shock
the cast so give me a little tease what
is that what's to come gotta watch is
there a path for Sandoval and Raquel to
exist in the Vanderpump Rules Universe
anymore I haven't had any contact with
Raquel so that's a bit of an unknown
quantity to me right now I think she
really needs to discuss with us what's
going on in her life but sandals been
part of that group
for
look 15 years prior you know four years
prior to the show so of course there's
conversations and questions to be
answered and I hope they can get to that
place that's what I really hope for them
I don't think you can just shut the door
on somebody I think we're all guilty of
some things maybe not that but you know
I think at some point there needs to be
kind of discussions and I think we'll be
there for it four Vanderpump dogs if
somebody couldn't make it to the gala
tonight can't contribute on this level
how do people at home get involved go to
bandapumpdogs.org you know it's it's a
family-run foundation we're working
people it was very difficult for us to
keep it going
um you know through through the pandemic
as our restaurants and our businesses
were closed but I actually managed to
raise 450 000 on cameo
me could you imagine how many happy
birthdays and wishes I did so that kept
us going
um they go to vanderbumpdogs.org it's
it's wonderful tonight just the people
who are here to support a Christian
Chenoweth who's got a book out all about
dogs and adoption she's singing and in
rehearsal we were crying just listening
to her she's this little tiny pretty
petite thing that's got this
unbelievable voice so very very excited
to see her tonight and you mentioned the
restaurants there's so much out there
about what's going on with pump is there
anything you want to clear up any
misinformation that's out there oh yes
there's always a different story the
lease expires
um or it's expired and we're just kind
of keeping it going for another couple
of months I'd like to see pride out
because that's such a big part of our
lives every year but yes we've had it
for 10 years you make a decision when
you're in this business to either renew
or to walk away and we decided with
everything that was going on and we're
opening two more restaurants to walk
away it was just really too expensive at
least now those will be in Vegas and
we'll see you there for bravocon oh yeah
you've got to be there well once in
Vegas I'm not telling you where the
other one is